60 years ago i was 11 years old radio
was the medium of the 1960s at least
when i was growing up it was great i
loved it and i used to tape record radio
programs not just
programs but music and commercials and
things like this
one commercial stuck in my mind when i
was 11 saying there's something wrong
with this commercial
this doesn't scan for me i don't like it
i was 11 years old and i couldn't figure
out what was wrong with it but it felt
wrong let me play it for you and you can
hear the same thing and probably you'll
instantly recognize what's wrong with
his radio jingle
[Music]
[Applause]
and add three more beans like party
three rich healthy yes you get 43 beans
in every cup i've never made a real
coffee bean that's all there is in
escape 43 beans in every cup make
nescafe they all called the
i'm sure that you realize what i realize
now but young 11 year old cliff did not
realize
two beans times two beans isn't four
beans
basic algebra says two beans times two
beans is four beans squared
it's dimensionally wrong
almost the first thing you learn in
physics is watch those units if you
square the number you'd better square
the units also two kilometers times two
kilometers is four square kilometers two
inches times two inches for those in
america is four square inches so what's
a square beam
damned if i know but then they go worse
they're not satisfied
with mucking up
dimensional analysis
it's dimensionally inhomogeneous two
beans times two beans is four beans
nescafe gives you lots more beans
four beans times ten beans
and add three more beans well let's
think about the dimensionality of that
four beans times ten beans ten beans
four beans and add three more beans like
party three rich healthy beans you
cannot add square beans to ordinary
beans
you don't get 43 beans you get 40 square
beans plus
three ordinary beans
so
let's look at that and take them a
little bit seriously so they said two
beans times two beans which is four
square beans can i use this as a
chalkboard get some sharpies
i got sharpies by the time okay
oh yeah i just don't remember what the
lyric was two beans times two beans is
four beans
hold on for a second
two beans
times two beans
is
four
bean squared
what are we adding
nescafe uses lots more beans
maybe ten beans times four beans and add
three more beans oh let's stop right
there ten beans times
four
beans
and add three more beans
makes what
ten beans times four beans is forty
bean squared
plus
three
beans is equal to
hey this is a quadratic equation 40 b
squared plus three b equals what are
they supposedly getting this four beans
from what they thought yeah okay so
that's so that's not in addition that's
we forget that now we just they've just
like so that should really be four being
squared
yes uh grady you've got it
great i said grady nice to meet you
cliff
[Laughter]
so one way of looking at this is to take
each lyric as a separate arithmetic
algebraic statement another way to do it
would be what brady has in his mind of
combining them
let's first take nescafe afterward lyric
by lyric well they said ten beans times
four beans and add three more beans make
well this equals 43
beans
so let's solve this as a quadratic
10 beans
times 4 beans plus 3
beans equals 43 beans easy to subtract
three beans from each each side and you
get ten beans square ten
oh oops
forty
square beans
equals subtract three b from each side
equals 40
b
so 40
square beans
equals 40 beans let's divide by b on
both sides and we get 40 beans equals
40.
well solve that by dividing by 40 on
both sides we find that
beans equals one
oh you get one bean
[Music]
[Laughter]
no all right yeah
yeah
let's start this all over again
would you want the brown piper then huh
let's look at the next equation that
they're talking about
okay somebody's at the front door okay
let's look at the next
okay
clearly the first equation of this
nescafe jingle is wrong two beans times
two beans isn't four beans it's four
beans squared four being squared
but what about the second nescafe
equation
ten beans times four beans and add three
more beans makes forty
rich coffee beans
so let's scribble it down
10 beans
times four beans and add three more
beans and add three more beans makes
43
rich coffee beans let's solve this
substituting b for beans
10 b
times 4 b
plus 3 3b
equals 43 b
combine terms on the left we find first
multiply this
40
b
squared
combine these on the left side 40 b
squared minus 40 b is zero that's a
quadratic equation so that's some kind
of
interesting equation let's factor it
so if you factor it it graphs into a
parabola and it factors into
40 b
times b
minus 1
which says it's got real roots it's got
a root at 0
forty times zero times zero minus well
yep that's right also has root at one
forty times one minus four yep
so
oh
come on turn on turn
zero and 1 are the roots of this
quadratic
they're the values of b that's what a
bean is yeah yeah well that's the
solution to this nescafe equation
on the other hand suppose we expand the
entire jingle combine the first part
dimensionally inaccurate with the second
part dimensionally and homogeneous
and let's see what we get then suppose
instead of four beans i say four being
squared yeah so let's try it there okay
ten beans
times
four
beans squared plus three
beans equals
43 beans now things get really tasty
let's solve this one this part is easy
same as before minus 40 b
10 b times 4 d squared is
40 b
cubed b times b squared
40 b cubed minus 40 b equals zero well
let's get rid of the
uh
40s and we find that we get a cubic
b
cubed minus
b
equals zero
that's an interesting cubic okay first
of all it's obvious zero is a solution
zero is the root of that guy uh i'll
leave it to the viewer to figure out the
solution to b cubed minus b is zero
obviously zero solves it um but
another interesting question is uh
what's 43 beans i think
yes yes yes yes yes yes
i put 43 beans into a klein bottle so as
to make at least one of these
mathematicians happy so i put 43 uh
beans into a klein bottle actually it
smells nice having coffee beans
at this point it's worth saying
that coming full circle
oops beans in every cup in fact one of
these fell out so this i don't care two
mathematicians alfred ray and paul
erdesh have been
credited with saying a mathematician is
a device to turn
coffee into theorems
it didn't occur to me
that this would work in a very literal
way and so before any number of
mathematicians on my wall i'd say my
smiles to you from oakland california
it's cliffstall
[Music]
this episode has been sponsored by the
brilliant people at brilliant
you must know them by now makers of
interactive online courses puzzles
problems things that are going to tickle
your brain make you smarter
i love how interactive everything is all
the sliders and movable parts they
really give you a feeling for the
problems they get your mind working in
new ways
i love this stuff it always brings a
smile to my face they say it's suitable
for ages 10 to 110 but surely 9 and 11
year olds are going to enjoy these two
go and have a look it's brilliant.org
number file that url is going to get you
20 off a premium subscription you can
also give brilliant as a gift and there
really is something for everyone
it only weighs 60 or 70 pounds
a portable calculator smaller than a
piano you can't get cooler than that
let's try to just
add three crank this around once
three
once
is three
again
three plus three is six
again
nine and then twelve
fifteen